- I'm trying to give you
some options for your ending.
I hate sushi.
- It is definitely a food
I could eat every day,
no problem.
- Juice vendors at the
mall, when they're like
"free smoothie?"
Always, yes, you take the smoothie.
- This is nigiri sushi,
it's a type of sushi.
- Also, Louise is out sick
today, so I get to eat
his burrito.
Five days of this, no problem.
Five months, no problem.
Maybe five years.
- You can't take sushi from an Asian man.
- You can take smoothie from a white girl.
I got this smoothie,
and then I brought this
smoothie from home.
But a burrito every day, I
feel like he's going to start
feeling really ill.
- Happy!
This shit's expensive.
- Yeah, I'm on a budget.
Damn good.
- This is great, Louise!
- Day two!
- Louise is sick again,
so we are eating his--
oh, you're eating the whole thing?
- He's eating the whole thing.
- I'm sorry.
- Can I have a sip of it?
- No.
- Can I just please have a sip?
- I'm good.
- I'm gonna do this all the time.
Whoa, who is this?
- Look who decided to show up!
We were just so sure you
weren't going to be here
that Kyle just got the shitty burrito.
- Is it making you feel any better?
- No.
- It's kind of stupid to
think that you could become
sick of sushi.
- You know how much my student
loan bill is every month?
This could be leaking out of my eyeballs
and I still wouldn't complain.
- I mean appetizing, not
really, but it's free, so like--
- You're gonna eat it.
- I'm gonna eat it.
- Day four!
Let's talk about your poops.
- I've got a feeling
there's gonna be some poops.
- I have like an iron
stomach, so it takes a lot
to really, like, make my poops weird.
- It's been an emotional journey.
- What journey? You haven't been here!
It is--
- Day five!
- The wow factor is a
little bit like, dull.
- Yeah, the wow factor is gone,
but I'm still happy with it.
- I have no problem
with breakfast burritos.
- I feel like the goal of
this video was to have us
be sick of our favorite
food, but, you know,
there's people starving out there.
That's not this kind of video.
We're grateful.
- I could go on.
- Yeah, I could do this every day forever.
I have to burp, will you pat my back?
- By the way, so was your--
(belches)
Whoa!
- Oh my God, I smell that.